hello everyone welcome to the active
inference lab today it is august 10th
2021 and we're here in live stream
number 26.1 discussing bayesian
mechanics for stationary processes
welcome to the active inference lab if
it's your first time or not
we are a participatory online lab that
is communicating learning and practicing
applied active inference you can find us
at the links here on this slide
this is a recorded and an archived live
stream so please provide us with
feedback so that we can improve on our
work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome here and we'll be following good
video etiquette for live streams so
people can just raise their hand
visually or in the jitsi if they want to
speak
this short link here has our calendar of
live streams for the year
and we're here in number 26 where today
on the 10th and then next week on the
17th we're going to be continuing
discussion on the bayesian mechanics for
stationary processes paper
and then we're going to launch into some
other papers so take a look at that link
if you want to learn more
today in live stream number 26.1 the
goal is going to be to learn and discuss
thankfully and really appreciatively
with some of the authors of the paper
we're going to be discussing this
bayesian mechanics for stationary
processes paper
and
asking questions writing things down we
want to look up over the coming week and
just seeing
what is uh
fun to talk about in this paper
so we'll start with just an introduction
and a warm-up of the non-authors and
then we'll go to the authors for
conveying anything that they'd like to
just at the outset
so i'm daniel and i'm a postdoc in
california i'll pass it to awful
work in the air modern collective
intelligence
i founded and coordinate the kerosene
research laboratory on building
inactive models for navigating the
anthropocene
thank you let's go to stephen and then
dean
hello welcome my name's steven syllett
i'm based in toronto and uh looking
forward to hearing the new developments
in active influence this paper covers
great and then
dean
good morning i'm i'm dean i'm a
retired guy i live in calgary and i'm
trying to
see what uh new insights can be provided
by all this math because it's quite
impressive to me
cool so on to lance and conor whichever
one of you would like to go first and
sort of
give us the give us the big picture and
how we got here and how you got to this
work before we jump into the paper
do you want to go
uh you you should go headlines right
um so so hi everyone and thanks for
inviting me daniel
so my name is lance and i'm doing a phd
in math and neuroscience in london
with uh cal pristine and greg pavliotis
and basically i i came to writing this
paper and doing this kind of research
because i'm interested in the question
of artificial intelligence
and i think
a lot of people who are doing machine
learning are approaching the question
from an engineering perspective
but i'm more interested in the
scientific perspective the scientific
question of what intelligence is what
intelligence is
and what do we really need to to create
an intelligent system
and so
um
researching around what what people were
doing i i found about i found out about
the free energy principle
and to me was um
the most mathematical piece of work
that i had that i had seen in
neuroscience and it seemed like it could
encompass many things
and he also had applications in active
inference
to model the brain and
ungenerate autonomous agents
and so now in my phd my goal is to
deeply understand the free energy
principle
and
to to lay out the mathematical
foundations because i think the free
energy principle started out as an
intuition
and gradually people have
tried to to make it more formal and
grounded in mathematics
um and so this is what we're trying to
do in this paper so it's not
this paper is not the end but i think
it's a step forward
so i'm really excited to
to share it and
ex
like talk about it with you guys
awesome sounds really cool about
starting as an intuition and then
working to ground in mathematics or or
then would it be grounded in intuition
and then elaborated with mathematics so
connor
yeah thanks i'm happy to be here um and
good morning good afternoon to some of
you depending on the time zone
so yeah my name is connor heinz i'm a
phd student at the max punk institute
for animal behavior the department of
collective behavior in constance germany
and i'm co-advised by
carl fristen at ucl and then ian cousin
who's my advisor in constance i'm in the
u.s at the moment uh but yeah so i
i'm also generally interested in
bayesian mechanics i think so lance and
i started our our phds at the same time
and ever since i found out that lance
was also interested in kind of the
mathematical foundations of the free
energy principle we've been in
discussions about bayesian mechanics for
a long time so i was really grateful
that he invited me to contribute to this
paper
and kind of it relates to my own
interests because i actually used to be
more involved in neuroscience now i've
moved more onto the idea that
any generic complex system can be
described as engaging in a kind of
process of approximate bayesian
inference and so i'm exploring that in
my own research in the context of
collective collective behavior so in
particular things like collective motion
like schooling and fish and flocking and
birds
so this paper i think
it gets at kind of the mathematical
foundations of sentience and autonomy in
all kinds of systems not just
nervous systems so that's why the the
framing in terms of stochastic processes
i think is really powerful because it
allows us to extend the framework to all
kinds of complex adaptive systems not
just the ones we might associate the
predictive coding free energy
formulation with like brains
thanks and a really nice point that like
there's activity in the nervous system
but it's not moving or the subunits are
not moving around so what are the
similarities and the differences or
what's the framework that's going to
allow us to
accommodate systems that are moving
around like the schools of fish flocks
of bird and then systems where the
topology is either fixed or slowly
changing
and
we have to do similar kinds of dynamical
analyses so also welcome dave
so stephen i see your hand raised go for
it and then anyone else who wants to ask
a question at this stage yeah just i'd
like to comment i think that was thanks
for the introductions and those insights
i think um you know as there's been this
progression oh
we've gone from bayesian approaches and
how we had predictive processing
approaches and active influence approach
approaches it's it's nice to also think
about okay once we start to generalize
it can be nice to go back
um to the bayesian
for idea more broadly and see okay
now the active influence supports all of
that you could then start to open the
net so to speak so i'm interested in a
lot of community psychology approaches
and
even interactive theater and immersive
theater where you're trying to work with
people's sense-making so i like that
re-broadening to maybe a more heuristic
mindset
so i thought that was interesting
cool so anyone can raise their hand um
if at any point but
let me just maybe start with our as we
tiptoe to the edge of the paper like
what brought you
either of the authors to this framing
did you find something in the junkyard
that was looked over or was there
something that was already being worked
on and you wanted to introduce a new
thread or how did it come to be composed
and worked on in this way
um
well so that there has been um
so i think kel fristen has been working
like for the past decade
trying to put
mathematics uh on the free energy
principle and trying to explain why
um
so as i mentioned before i think the
free energy principle started out as an
intuition
and i think he has been working for the
past decade
in on a mathematical theory or a
physical theory for why the free energy
principle
should hold um
as an explanation for
what the brain is doing
and so
what we wanted to do in this paper is to
um to actually take take these
developments uh that were mostly coming
from physics
um and that weren't necessarily as
general as they could be or as
mathematically rigorous as they could be
and actually put it on a fair
mathematical framework
and try to explain it clearly and
i mean as clearly as possible
so that was the goal here
so what do you think that intuition was
or maybe there's a lot of ways that i'm
sure fristen and others have said it but
what is the intuition that at least you
are pursuing with this work
right um so i think
the the intuition
so i think it came it came from two two
different ways um from from two
different ideas so so the first idea is
if you come from machine learning
and you look at machine learning from a
very broad perspective you look at many
different algorithms
and you look at what they do you look at
many different problems and you look at
what they do
and it actually turns out um and i think
that's something that people started to
realize in the early like 2000s
that a lot of these
algorithms arguably all of these
algorithms they can be seen as
minimizing free energy
um
and so we without getting
deeply into that um i think the moral of
the story is that
a lot of the things that working in
machine learning
are special cases of minimizing free
energy so of doing some kind of base and
inference
and so many of these problems you can
think of them as like special cases of
base and inference
so i think if you come from machine
learning
then would be quite natural to say
or at least you could say oh
approximate inference or free energy
minimization
is the most general thing you can do in
machine learning
and therefore since the brain engages in
some kind of cognition
it seems reasonable to assume that it
may be doing some kind of basin
difference
an approximate base inference so
minimizing free energy is the most
general way to look at it so that's one
way to get to a free energy principle
but maybe it's not very convincing so i
think
the other
the other way you could get to a free
energy principle
um which is more grounded in physics
and i think that was like um the content
of the original papers
is that if you look at a system that
persists over time
um
so a system that does not dissipate
then you can show
that it has to be optimizing something
um
and there and then you
there has to be optimizing some what
people call model evidence
so the this system must have like uh
implicitly or explicitly a model of its
environment
and it has to be optimizing in order not
to dissipate it has to be optimizing
that model
and then you can show that
um
actually minimizing free energy enables
you to do that
so i think that's the the other way um
anyway so so what we did in this paper
is we we took this intuition
of what it means to persist
so so we
there's like actually a clear way of
thinking about those things in uh in
mathematics and stochastic processes
so what we do in this paper is we look
at systems that persist over time
and
we also look at systems so that's the
first assumption and then the second
assumption
is that the system has to be separated
by a boundary with its environment
and i think i mean intuitively it makes
sense because we we're looking at
systems that are bounded
uh with their environment so they
interact
via a markup blanket but they cannot mix
per se with the system it's not like
milk and coffee if you wish
it's like a person in an environment so
it's
well defined in space
um so these are the two things that we
assume in this paper and then we show
that
you can actually
describe the system as minimizing free
energy in some way
thanks for that it's interesting about
the machine learning branch towards the
fep and then the physics branch because
of course there's also sort of the third
leg of that triangle with the physics
and machine learning so
we go from that just a interdisciplinary
connection or an interface
to add in the third which is this active
inference or the free energy type
framings and all of a sudden some of the
ideas that were a little bit hard to to
map from machine learning and physics
kind of come around the horn and maybe
there's a way that we can
see active inference playing a role
there so again anyone can just raise
their hand if they have a question or
write a question in the live chat
here's the road map
so these were the sections of the paper
which
introduced that boundedness notion of
the markov blanket
discussed basic mechanics active
inference and stochastic control and
then had a nice discussion and
conclusion with a few
supplemental sections so
what went into how you laid out the
arguments or
what sections do you think were um
condensed or which ones would you want
to expand on more so first just to the
authors on that and then avo your
question
hello lance and
[Music]
wait commer
i have a question uh before we get into
detail i'm curious whether you were
aware
of the kind of criticism that an
activist launched at the french
principle in suffocation in cognitive
science
right could you mention what what
specific criticism we're talking about
okay so i'm referring to the paper
laying down a path by di paolo
thomson and beer
um there is a lot of criticism that is
just
completely out
unrelated to anything that uh acting
says but the core
thing that seems relevant to me
is the role of creation and historicity
and
well self-creation
in cognition intelligence and life
so yeah the paper just i'm going to put
it in the chat is laying down a forking
path incompatibilities between an action
and the free energy
principle so
first to the authors for any thoughts on
that and then see stephen with a hand
raised
right um
so so i haven't read this particular
paper
um
so i i can i can't give you an answer
that's specific to this particular paper
um i would say
i would say from a general point of view
so yeah there's a lot of criticism on
the free energy principle
and i think it's natural because the
free energy principle aims to be
seems to be very general it's also an
extremely ambitious
um in in regards to to the criticism so
far
it's it's either been on the on the
mathematics
and so this is something that we've
fixed with the with the current paper so
i think a lot of the mathematical
criticism in the literature
is void
i mean is rendered void by by this paper
and there are there are other um
i would say philosophical criticisms uh
on the free energy principle so it's not
something i'm
expert about because i'm i'm a
mathematician so i wouldn't be able to
to really debate about the philosophy
here
um i i so i i'm not aware of
like uh daniel you said you put the link
to the paper in the chat oh i'll put it
in this i'll put it in the jitsi chat in
just a second okay because i i meant i
noticed you mentioned the words like
creation and historicity
um i'm not aware of the particular
argument but an argument that
i've heard against the free energy
principle that reminds me of what you
just said and this is one of the more
philosophical arguments not the
mathematical things that lance just
mentioned is the idea that
the free energy principle the inference
interpretation of a system with a markup
blanket at steady state it rests on the
idea of a steady state so basically
there's an invariant measure of the
system over time
and when people have tried to say relate
or claim that something like societies
or
large-scale socio-cultural or
socio-technical systems are engaging in
free energy you kind of have to enforce
this assumption of a stationary uh a
stationary steady-state distribution on
the system
and so when you say things like
historicity i think of like revolutions
or something right so that kind of
things where the the kind of intrinsic
nature of the system seems to shatter or
fundamentally change and that would seem
to question
um
the or violate the steady-state
assumption which is kind of a baseline
thing you need in order for the free
energy principle maths to apply
um i can respond to that argument but i
don't actually know if that's the
argument laid out in this paper that's
just kind of what my brain jumped to
when you mention things like historicity
and
creation and destruction
is that is that the the core of the
argument though or
uh so thing like a revolution is not
necessarily a sign of historicity it can
be a predetermined in the um
in the formulation of the dynamical
system but uh
what i'm speaking about in the medical
terms is the presence of the of
difficulties that will be reversible if
for example uh we have we drive on the
uh where am i right of the road because
uh some guy said so like 200 years ago
and this
does not leave the law ever this is an
example of uh
walking
or path dependency or historicity
uh so that is the kind of argument that
di paulo and thompson and beer are
averaging
but it is um formally not proportionate
because advocacy does not entail the
absence of historicity
it's bernoulli systems that do not show
historicity ergotic system only do not
show like irreversible
transitions which is a much quicker
condition
but where
there is a convergence
to a better argument is that
to have a space or description of a
dynamical system you have to assume as
you assume
wait
english is broken assume that this space
is
fixed throughout the evolution of a
system and if we agree with an activists
and a system biologists like kaufman and
montebell and
metro monteville
that
core property of the integrity system is
to uh well make sense uh to find
observables and to create solutions to
problems did not exist
beforehand then the um
the stat space is not fixed it's created
along the systems evolution this is not
something you can account with a
stat space description of chemical
system
uh that has a state attractive state
distribution sorry
yeah i i think i would agree that
as it currently stands the free energy
principle couldn't deal the math
couldn't deal with um varying state
spaces where literally the actual
interpretations or like the the finite
dimensionality of the system states is
changing over time usually you assume
some fixed integer dimension for all the
stochastic processing stuff although i'm
maybe lance could comment on that i'm
sure that could potentially be extended
to infinite dimensional like partial
differential equation style formulations
but uh based i if i understood you
correctly the first part of what you
said about path dependence and
irreversibility
that is all totally acute uh
accommodated by the maths laid out in
lance's paper so there's a very you know
strong part of the flow that is
irreversible another way of describing
that as you could say there's a strong
degree of path dependence in the
trajectories of the system so path
dependence per se is totally
accommodated
and easily um you know path dependent
systems can can fit into the free energy
framework but the state space changing
itself over time that's something that i
haven't really even thought about um
it's an interesting argument but i i
would agree that i don't think the free
energy principle currently is equipped
to deal with like the state space itself
being altered over time that's usually
assumed to be fixed but i don't know
maybe lance has a different opinion on
that
right um yeah i completely agree with
conor so in this paper we don't discuss
changing state spaces
and i think in terms of future work that
would be really
really the next step
um so so i think the the current
formulation
uh gives a mathematical framework to
think about adapting systems
but it doesn't
um
it doesn't really talk about
like environments that structurally
change over time for example
thanks um steven and then we can
continue on on this
i think this also speaks to that the
legs of that stool that was being talked
about earlier if you're coming from a
math and machine learning you've got
um
you know you've got more
lower dimensional approaches but they
show the principles and then when you
get into the inactive approaches
they're looking more from a biological
perspective
so it might also be a little bit around
the very high complexity but the my
understanding is that
the
dependency and ergodicity and also the
ability to do approximation
science
uh interpretations of the machine
learning
does start to make
this math
overcome some of those limitations um
because it it has more
i i i that's my understanding is that
the the reliance on ergodicity is not as
rigid now
so
let's
go to the markov blanket and then return
to some of these important distinctions
like ergotic systems steady state
stationary
so i'm gonna put the uh markov blanket
up through time figure three um figure
one has just sort of the the timeless
the classic blanket and then figure
three
is adding a subscript t
so having that
uh those variables describe time
dependent functions since that's kind of
what we're talking about with the
dynamical systems
so maybe
to the authors like how do you
summarize what this graphical figure
means what is it being what is being
blanketed what does it mean to blankets
and then how does that relate to steady
state or stationary distributions which
are in the title of the paper
right
so the the mark of blanket is really the
way the mathematical way in which you
you talk about boundaries
um
and so having a markup blanket simply
means that the internal states here
they're separated by
they're separated from the external
states by the blanket states
and then
the fact that uh the system is at steady
state uh means that the the blanket
persists over time
and so this is really the two things
that we need when we're talking about
um a biological system
or or a stone
so we need we need something internal
to the stone or the biological system
something external and then some kind of
interface
and of course when you're talking about
something very simple like a stone it's
not very interesting because you don't
have
any exchanges between what's internal
and external
via the blanket but when you're talking
about biological systems like like cells
or or bacillus you do have exchanges
of matter of energy and information and
that's something that you can
accommodate with the markup blanket
that's
it's almost a tension in the definition
of boundedness which is you said well
there is a boundary but then also it's
exchanging matter energy information
so what
is the boundaries meaning
uh if those are allowed to pass through
it conor and then anyone else
uh i'm unmuted right no no you're good
i'm good okay yeah yeah so i would uh i
would say
that's a great question because
basically the the boundary we're talking
about isn't when you take a boundary for
like a physical system people often
make assumptions about causality so that
something on one side of the blanket
can't affect something on the other side
of the blanket but because of this
exchange of matter and energy across the
blanket the the actual definition of the
markup blanket is a statistical one it
just means that this boundary
is
statistically in a sense segregates the
internal on the outside and and that
statistical separation can actually
critically differ from just direct
causal interactions so the actual
definition of the markov blink in a
statistical sense
is that the internal states when
conditioned
on the blanket states
are statistically independent of the
external states and vice versa the
external states when conditioned on
blanket states are statistically
independent of the internal states and
just saying that definition might not
make the intuition any more clear but
that really is all that it is
um so then when we actually look at the
dynamics of particular physical or
systems or stochastic processes
that statement cannot entail all kinds
of causal graphs and all kinds of
influences between those subsets
um it's really the statistical
independence
which which defines the boundary
um yeah so i think that's that's kind of
the kernel of the definition and for
certain kinds of statistical
distributions we can actually really
precisely look at the structure of
things like the stationary covariance
which is basically the covariance matrix
of the process at steady state and you
can read off
what systems are outside the blanket
what what subsets of variables outside
the blanket what subsets are inside the
blanket which subsets the variables are
the blanket
um so it's a really precise definition
that kind of
goes beyond whatever intuitions you
might bake into that on your own about
causality
awesome points so survival
sorry
does this not entail that blanket if
there is any causal interaction between
internal and external states then
blanket states would mediate this causal
interaction because if they did not then
you would have information that will go
directly from external to internal or
vice versa so um
settlement is correct then there is some
causal sense to blankets
is it correct or not
yeah yeah definitely and that's a really
good point
um so really what the blanket does
is uh to to separate the inside from the
outside statistically and so what that
means is that
any information
about the internal states that
any transmission of information on
anything about the internal states that
influences external states has to do
through the blanket states
um so there is a notion of causality but
but it's like they
as you said the internal and external
cannot affect each other directly they
have to do it through the blanket
okay thank you
awesome so dean
and then stephen
yeah this might be a strange question
but that's fine so the blank so the
blankets kind of we just use that as a
way of describing the interface my
question is and i cuz i
most of the math that you guys use is is
over my head but i appreciate that
you've been able to come up with it my
question is
we're thinking about this metaphorically
does the blanket
come with its own perforations i mean we
talk about it acting as a mediator but
is there a math that can kind of show
it's it's it's it's managing this
information flow back and forth but does
it already exist with these perforations
present or
is the how is the math going to tell us
how that that
medium works or is it did you guys
already explain that because maybe i
just didn't appreciate it when i read
the paper
um
yeah that's a really good question so we
didn't expand on that in the paper um
and so it's good that we talk about it
now
so
the definition of markup blanket
as it is taking the paper
allows for boundaries that are
completely opaque so without any kind of
transmission but also boundaries that
would let anything through
so
so it with this formalism is is quite
general um
and so far we don't make any assumptions
about the structure of the blanket and
so it could be very permeable not very
permeable
you could have all sorts of things
um and and i think that that's also
really interesting because
then i mean ultimately we want a theory
that describes biological systems and so
the blanket states have some degree of
permeability in
in in biological systems that we can
actually exploit mathematically
so we don't we don't do that here here
the blanket is
completely arbitrary and so you could
describe a stone but it could also
describe
maybe a brain or a rat or something like
this
but then in the future would be really
interesting to actually
impose some more structure on the
blanket to see whether we can say
anything more interesting about the
system that we're looking at
thanks
steven
i think this is a
an area that's probably going to be
growing a lot is how much of that
transfer
process of information from the infinite
almost external states
gets onto a blanket and then gets
transferred to the internal states
so the question is normally everyone
talks about changing the generative
model
but there is obviously a question what
what can you change in terms of the
blanket but i think
i don't think that's been
fully explored yet so but i think that's
a big area that
i suppose could be seen as part of the
generative model or the regime of
attention but
it sounds like this the mathematical
model here is starting to be able to
engage that more if it was expanded
yeah let's walk through a few
steps of the paper because that's really
where we're we're building up this
intuition or moving from the intuition
and scaffolding it with the math
so first you phrase
the blanket as intervening states
between internal and external states
and defined the state space
that those
different internal external and blanket
states can exist in so totally subject
to to servals
comments about state space
and
um maybe it'd be helpful to explain this
big pie so what is the covariance
precision
what are we talking about with these
matrices
what's a system with a certain type of
matrix structure that might help us get
a grasp on what the covariance matrix at
steady state is actually representing
about systems
right so so in the in our in our
scenario here the the matrix pi
actually encodes everything about um the
permeability of the branch of the
blanket but more generally
um how do the
internal states interact with blanket
states and how do the external states
interact with blanket state
so matrix spy really gives you
um yeah the structure of the interaction
and um
and yeah and so so we just simply showed
that the mark of blanket condition so
this boundary
actually is equivalent to some kind of
structure of the matrix by but then when
we try to differentiate um
living systems with non-living systems
and then intelligent systems from
non-intelligent systems then probably we
could say a lot more about this matrix
by
so like if there was non-zero everywhere
in pi
what would that correspond to or what
would it correspond to have all zeros
what does a big number or small number
mean in this precision matrix because
this is truly a key variable in these
formalisms
right
um
so so the
so one extreme would be the matrix by to
be the identity matrix
and then this would mean that
uh each state only interacts with itself
and so that that's like kind of an
extreme case of a markov blanket because
you have a boundary
but then you don't even have any
transmission with the boundary like you
have just three separate states external
blanket and internal that don't talk to
each other
and then the
the other extreme would be to
um to to have a non-zero non-zero entry
in the in the equation that we have
there
and then it would mean that
internal states and external states can
talk to each other directly without
interacting via the blanket scene so
then you don't have a blanket you just
have three states that mix with each
other
and so
yeah you do you lose
you lose kind of the the basic point
that says oh we're looking at systems
that have a boundary
um and and then in terms of the the
magnitude of the entries so a big
magnitude
would say um
i think i may get get it the
wrong way wrong way around but i think a
big magnitude is like you have a lot of
interaction and if you have a very low
magnitude you have very little
interaction
okay
great because this
variable is important and this
relationship between the one over the
precision and the variance is gonna come
up um a lot so we go from this idea of
using a matrix to represent
basically the statistical connectivity
of different nodes and then hope that
the structure of that matrix is such
that it falls out or designing
systems such that the structure of the
matrix falls out into internal external
and mediating blanket states
and then
you develop this notion that the
that there's an expected
uh internal state and external state
that are downstream of the blanket
states so what is happening with these
formalisms or how can it be that the
blanket state tells us about what to
expect internally and externally
um
so because you have a because you have a
boundary because you have these blanket
states
so so the whole
um so let me give you an example
uh if you think about a human
then for example part of the blanket
states would be what happens on your
retina so the impression from the world
that you get from in on the retina
and so
this is to say that if you have some
kind of sensory impression on your
retina then this gives you some
information about what's going on
outside
and so
um if if on your retina you see kind of
like a a certain shape maybe you you
maybe
the most like the thing that's going on
in the environment that corresponds to
that shape is a chair
and maybe actually that shape that you
see on your eyes like looks like a chair
so then you would say oh the most likely
external state
is a chair
um so this is all formalizing the fact
that the blanket states
what what you have on on your retina
gives you information about what's going
on outside
and also influences what's going on in
your brain because
you need to process that information
um
and so yeah so we have a most likely
external state and a most likely
internal state
any other
um uh thoughts on this because then
that's where we go from
oh
yes so connor go for it
yeah i'll just add that uh
it's critical that we're talking about
expectations here so that's why
we're
writing down like a normal distribution
that's centered on this expectation
because remember these are stochastic
processes so for any given blanket state
it doesn't mean that the internal state
on the other that directly is downstream
of that blanket state will always be
that expected one but this is just the
mean of the distribution but the
powerful thing about this uh the
bayesian mechanics for these uh gaussian
processes
is that those um expected states are
basically just linear functions of the
blanket states just given by these sub
matrices of the covariance and then
their inverses and such like that so
it's just important to know that if
we're to pursue this example of the
retina it's like
for any given retinal impression it
doesn't mean there's always going to be
the same cortical response right in
visual cortex or what have you but
there's going to be some distribution of
cortical responses and what we're
talking about right here is the mean of
that distribution
very
good point so steven and then anyone
else with a raised hand and then we'll
move forward
so
from what is you're saying there with
the
stochastic
processes is there's there's some
transfer
in a in a sort of a random kind of
informational sense
and obviously it's lossy as it goes
through and it's the ex the expectations
i suppose at some level have to have
have to be able to be confirmed or
disconfirmed or find some sort of
um
statistical correlation
to then actually use the information
that has to be i suppose at some point
there's just not enough there
to work anything out or the model's not
good enough to find it
i'll be interested in how much
do you have a sense of how much
tends to get through
or like how long it takes for
information to
be processable like if that's if there's
some sort of heuristic or whether that's
a little bit too unrealistic
yeah that's a really great question i
mean in the in the brain there's
evidence that you know
you can get pretty complex i'm not a
vision neuroscientist but you can get
pretty deep in the cortical hierarchy
even up to the level of a decision
within you know 150 or sometimes less
milliseconds
um so that's almost kind of so this is
another big important thing to discuss
about this paper is
the information processing we're talking
about here is on the level of
expectations right so if the brain is
really
processing like an immediate retinal
impression it doesn't have time to
average across a ton of no like tons of
parallel noise realizations
like
and then and then use the expected value
to actually do its processing this so
the the brain in any given moment is
actually just getting stochastic
realizations and then it's using
information processing on those
realizations
so i would also i don't know how lance
feels about this but i would hesitate in
reading in like the expected
cortical state given a particular
blanket state i would i would with
restraint from reading that as the
informational currency that the brain
actually works with
um
so there is information uh transfer but
it's not like the brain always has to
work with expectations it can work with
um stochastic samples
at any given moment but that's also like
a controversial thing in
in neuroscience right now it's like what
is the actual information the brain is
working with but the fact that the
latency on decision making can be so
short suggests that the brain isn't
really averaging over a bunch of
parallel realizations of something in
order to do a computation
another piece is that on this slide
we're talking about the expectation in
terms of the the mean the average value
of a distribution conditioned upon
blanket states we're talking about
average value
of internal states conditioned on
blanket states we haven't yet introduced
this question about internal states
expecting or making a prediction about
external states so it's almost like
expectation is being used um as just the
sort of broad statistical concept that
you can condition expectation on some
other variables or
the systems that we kind of care about
and are interested in the ones where the
internal states are acting as if they
are
making expectations or predictions about
external states which is where
it's taken in the immediate following
section of the paper
that's a really good point yeah
what is the sigma
function so i know there's some related
um work
uh like with miguel that we saw a little
bit about like
what is the sigma what kinds of
gaps in the formalism does the sigma
cover
um
how did it come to be this way with the
mapping function and what does it
reflect
right um so i would say that the sigma
is the most
fundamental
ingredient to get to the free energy
principle
because ultimately we want to be able to
save uh what we want to be able to say
or or say
say that happens or or doesn't happen is
that
the internal states have some kind of
representation about the external states
uh and so the way to get there is to
actually have a sigma function
that
gives that maps from the
expected internal state or expected
cortical response
to
the expected external state like what's
going on around you
so there there needs to be some
uh we need we need to find uh like a
relationship between internal states and
external states to be able to say
anything about inference
and so what what we do in in this paper
is we give
conditions
under which um you you have this mapping
sigma
and then you you're able to say oh we
have some kind of inference going on
and
i think in in terms of like a historical
perspective
so in previous papers the the sigma was
assumed
um and then and then miguel wrote this
paper saying oh the sigma
uh you need some assumptions to for the
sigma to work it doesn't it doesn't
always
uh sigma doesn't always exist
and so what we do in this paper is we we
give conditions under which sigma exists
and if these conditions fail and sigma
doesn't exist
and crucially i think
these conditions can be verified from
data
great
points here
um the
synchronization map and a few of these
other pieces relate to
the idea of an image
and a kernel
so
maybe it'd be helpful to learn a little
bit about what what are the image and
the kernel reflecting i found one
representation
about mapping the the uh two different
spaces to each other using that sort of
kernel and image notation but when
you're talking about um in lemma 2.1 the
existence of the sigma function
entailing
an image function that maps the internal
to the external states like what is an
image
what is the difference between just the
variable in itself versus an image of it
or a kernel of it
right so what we're trying to do is to
to map the expected internal state to
the expected external state
and so what we mean by image in the
first line here
is is simply that
yeah we're we're trying to map variables
that could be your expected cortical
responses so we don't care about
anything
that's not your expected political
response where
so we care about specific type of
variables
um
and then we're trying to map these to
expected external states so so that's
the first line
and so then here we
we just say that basically the the gist
of this result is that
if
if you have something that's going on in
the environment let's say there's a
chair in front of you and you get some
kind of expected cortical response
and then let's suppose there's a sofa in
front of you and you get the ex the same
expected political response
then you will have a problem because it
means that your organism cannot
differentiate between chairs and sofas
because it has the same cortical
response for the for the two
two different external states
and so what we're saying is that we
actually don't want that to happen
we want our organism to be able to
differentiate between different external
states
and so this is
um the the condition three and the
conditions for
uh they're both i mean each of them is
equivalent to one and so it puts on the
mathematical footing what it means to be
able to differentiate between
different states in the environment
[Music]
awesome thank you um serval and then
we'll ask a question from the live chat
so
for this thing to work you need organism
to be able to discriminate between any
two states of its environment is that
correct
um yeah so any two states that we model
not necessarily
um
yes i see that mapping like four b1 and
b2 being equal to each other
then it implies that the that the
external predictions are going to be the
same
yeah so if your expected cortical
responses are the same
then the expected states must be the
same
um so then again okay
this needs to be thought about in terms
of representations
so the the external world does not need
to be model modeled at the molecular
level so it's like
a model about the external world and so
maybe
in that model there there's things
yeah so so it can be like a coarse
grained model of the external world
okay so you use the example of a chair
in your sofa i'm pretty sure that
most of the listening people can do the
difference they're pretty sure that most
cats cannot
well i said a cat i fly it's smaller
why would a certain organism develop
representation of certain states under
the cringey principle
um so that that's a really good point
and i think to
to address that mathematically we would
need to
to actually investigate
a state space that changes over time
to actually to actually address the
question of how how things learn
representations
so that's not that's not what
uh we haven't done that far that far yet
but that's definitely an important thing
to to address in the future so what we
the the starting point here is
you start with a steady state you start
with a markov blanket
and you have uh so the representation is
already baked in in the markov blanket
and and so in the in this result we just
say oh if the mark of blanket looks like
this
then you have a good representation
if the markup blanket is uh sort of more
degenerate then you have a bad
representation
so in the in the next slide actually um
um
if you can put up the next slide
um so we show that if the if the
condition from the previous slide is not
met
then you then the organism would have a
degenerate type of representation where
for example it cannot differentiate
between cats and between uh chairs and
and sofas
and and that that i suppose is still
fine uh but it's
um
so so yeah it would like conflate
complete different external states
um so in this paper we assume that this
wouldn't happen because then it enables
you to
like derive results exactly
but you could assume that um the
organism conflates
different things and then you would have
some kind of semi-degenerate type of
representation
and then everything still carries out
but instead of saying oh
my organism does exact basic inference
and it's like super accurate and so on
uh you can only
um you can only say oh my organism maybe
is doing some kind of approximate
inference that's good in some instances
and bad in some other instances
so i think
um you can definitely relax relax that
condition and sort of assess and
directly
how accurate is your representation
okay
to reformulate any representation must
have a precursor sensory active state in
this framework
okay very interesting and also we're
still in the um inference section we
haven't introduced
policy planning or planning as inference
so it doesn't need to be the perfect
state estimator in order to make
adequate policy so
we've talked about that in many other
situations about action and loop and
everything so let's
look through the paper and then as we
build in pieces we can see where these
these different segments come into play
because we haven't talked about like
policy or conditioning inference on
policy yet so stephen and then i'll ask
the question from the chat
one thing that can also help think about
expectations and simplify or or
get away from the pressure of
representations is
that
the the blanket can be seen more like or
the perception visual perception is more
like an impressionist painter
painting
dabs
on a painting and then stepping out and
looking at it and we're just continually
like trying to find the textures and the
patterns in
that might help confirm our expectations
rather than it being like we see
the shape of the object it could be that
as long as we've seen the type of
textures
um that we're feeling in the space
um and that that some of that could be
done at the retina level there could be
certain things that just gets processed
so i i suppose just couching that in the
inactivist
world of you know really
when we say representation that's a bit
unloaded in that world so it could be
statistically
uh
predictable in some way
yep and we've talked about
representation and some of the different
views on representation and
axial constants uh work on the the
armstis and the representation war
so blue's question before we continue on
with exploring the formalism blue asked
uh do the maths that you have been
working with allow for altering the
structure or boundary of the blanket
itself for example if i go blind that
sensory state is no longer available
so how do we deal which is a little bit
we addressed earlier but there's like
different
senses that the models can be changing
they can be within the box
changing at steady state
or there are these other types of
changes that actually change the
structure of
the whole boundary or the internal model
itself so what kinds of changes
violate the model and which kinds of
changes are allowing us to continue
using the model
so uh
at the moment um
what the what this paper accommodates
are
sudden changes in the blanket so you
could at any point change change the
blanket and then see what happens so if
for example if you go blind you could
change the blanket accordingly and
and then everything would carry out
what this doesn't account for is
blankets that continuously change over
time
so for example if you're looking at an
organism throughout its lifetime
the organism would
after being born it would like grow and
age and so on
um so we do not accommodate that
but we we can accommodate sudden changes
in the nine kids
awesome thank you and also just anytime
people need to drop off is totally cool
so let's
take another look at that
markov blanket persisting through time
and
maybe even return a little bit to what
kinds of systems are we talking about
here
there was this very interesting piece in
example 3.1
about describing which types of
stochastic processes at the gaussian
steady state p
might fit under this phrasing
so several things were mentioned
conor how would you summarize this list
or is this an exhaustive list is this
just the tip of the iceberg what kinds
of attributes do these examples share
that allow them to fall under this
framework and then what violates it and
moves us into a different space
yeah so this is um so basically the
the the core set of stochastic processes
that we we deal with in this paper are
diffusion processes
um so that's just a particular type of
markov process
which means that basically the
current moment is totally
uh statistically dependent on the last
moment
um that's not to say that there
can't exist mathematics that uh apply
the free energy principle to other sorts
of stochastic processes that's probably
something that lance is also working on
at the moment
but um
if i was to give like some
i mean
markov prosthesis are very generic in
the sense that tons of
biological processes i think
and non-biological processes could be
cast as as markov processes
and i think there's also an important
aspect this is kind of
touched uh on a little bit in the next
section with integrator chains even
though you might say oh but like humans
have memory there's all kinds of deep
temporal dependencies
you can have very high dimensional
markov processes where with with
different
levels of time scales but at the lowest
level i think it's
a safe mathematical assumption to make
that things are markov process at the
most fine grained level so i think that
the these kinds of systems are
like pretty unrestricted in the kinds of
things they can capture everything you
know from financial markets are modeled
as diffusion processes the orange
dynamic process which is what we use in
this paper is a really popular
um process used to model things like uh
decision making like the drift diffusion
process which is used in kind of
alternative force choice decision making
tasks
um and then things like evolutionary
dynamics like genetic frequencies
drifting over time are modeled
as a stochastic like linear diffusion
processes
um
but i should also say that we use orange
strength
basically linear diffusions in this work
and that's how we get these nice linear
synchronization maps the mathematics are
all linear and easy
but uh this also applies to non-linear
um diffusion processes so where the
drift term basically isn't just a linear
map like a b like a big matrix like it
would be for an ou process but it could
also be some non-linear
very you know kind of
harsh function
um one some some other restrictions is
that the drift function so basically the
flow that
determines the motion of the next set of
states given the current state that mo
that drift function has to be smooth
that's another condition um in these
kinds of diffusion processes
um yeah that is i think i pretty much
cover it there's like some technical
things like a zigzag process i'm
actually not sure what that is that's
something to ask uh lance
great thanks
and what you said about that um the the
multiple levels of integration with the
integrator chains and about how that
addresses some of the comments about
historiosity um we can return to that
because there's some i think it's really
instructive so serval with a question
and then anyone else who wants to ask
one
yeah i have a question which is
mathematical in nature for a change
um
i don't get what this means for random
nuclear systems to other three states if
it is not ergotic because if it is
ergodic then due to well erasity
you can find a measure that says
something about how likely i am to find
a system in such or such
subspace you should not have the
hybridic conditions and you cannot
exchange a distribution for time average
i don't get
where what
where the distribution is coming from
exactly in the case uh where the system
is um
kind of deterministic
at least
yeah i can't think of an example off the
moment but there are processes that have
an invariant measure
where the time and the space averages
are not equivalent so if you just look
up
non-ergotic stationary processes i think
there's some
examples with
like discrete switching processes like
um bernoulli variables
where the the time and the space
averages will actually not be equivalent
so that so i think this
is
explicitly taking into account those
those kinds of systems
um where the time and the space average
wouldn't be equivalent so
for instance if you think about systems
with multiple basins of attraction that
might like stochastically jump between
those two basins of attraction
the space average there at any given
moment will not necessarily be
um equivalent like a bunch of parallel
realizations at any given moment the
space average of that might be centered
around one of the modes of that process
and that will actually be different than
the time average which would actually
give your distribution over both modes
so that's just something that that jumps
to mind but there are other examples of
stationary processes
where the space and time average are not
equivalent which is the definition of
ergodicity
okay but uh how do you define this as
the sorry steady state distribution then
what does it mean and what are the
conditions for it to be defined
so a steady state distribution
basically just means that the statistic
the sufficient statistics that define it
uh do not vary over time
um so they're invariant they're constant
basically
um so
for for a gaussian process the mean does
not change over time
and the covariance does not change over
time
so that's that's an example
um yeah i mean so the the definition of
the stationary state actually if
if you get down to the fundamentals of
it i would more say the stationary state
is actually just a property of the flow
so the flow that the stochastic
differential equation itself like the
ito style differential equation that's
the most fundamental structure of any
system
and the stationary state actually is
just something whose gradients drive the
flow
so rather than um
but but that's more an interpretational
point but in terms of the actual okay
stationary i guess so steady state
okay but you have stationary i guess i
know what stationary is and you have as
a state which is defined if i understand
well but distribution p
the question is how do you define a
distribution of a generical system in
the general case of a stationary nickel
system
so the way you define it formally is you
define basically the the a partial
differential equation that tells you the
density of the of the system at every
time point and that partial differential
equation is called the fock or planck
operator and then you basically set the
derivative of that partial differential
equation equal to zero and then you
solve for the density
so that's the most like minimal bare
bones definition i can give you of the
of the steady state is the density which
is the solution to the focker plank
operator when the focker plank operates
derivative with respect to time zero
that's the stationary state so another
way of saying that is if i start the
stochastic process in a bunch of
different places and run it over time
all those processes will converge to the
solution to the focker blank operator
which is the the steady state density
okay and for what kind of system do we
have a stable solution
for this
rather than say uh
i don't have the words original
attractor something that switches and uh
i don't know goes to uh
new places like expensive process
um yeah so the precise condition there's
basically conditions on the drift that
will tell you whether the system
explodes or whether it converges so for
instance for an ou process
those solutions to the focker plank
operator
are
defined when the eigen values of the
drift matrix are not too big for
instance
but what the actual conditions are for
all sorts of stochastic processes such
that there are unique solutions to the
focker plank operator i am i'm not sure
i'm not an expert on
uh on stochastic processes that's
something that lance might be able to
give a more rigorous definition to but
it really depends on the drift um
basically the f function which tells you
whether the system has a invariant
measure or basically a unique solution
and sometimes there's multiple solutions
to the focker blank operator which means
that you know the system will end up in
one thing or another
thanks for these
helpful explanations just one comment
before dean's question is that sometimes
the steady state can be at a higher
moment so like in the example of a car
there's like the position and then
there's how fast it's moving and then
etc higher and higher derivatives and so
the integrator chains and variational
inference allow us to find an invariance
at a higher level of the distribution
that even as the actual position of the
car is changing like that a stationary
process doesn't mean the car is not
moving it just means there's something
about the car's movement
that we can continue to integrate or
derive towards
finding a statistical invariance
specifically one that's structured kind
of like this
where it's almost like a diffusion
process or a flow
across a field
so those are some of the pieces that
link together and so it's not just that
that the position has to be well behaved
it might look very non-linear but we're
using certain ways of breaking down the
problem so that at each level we can
frame it as this like linked
sequence of tractable calculations
so
connor if you have anything to add on
that or dean you can question yeah i
think that's a really good point like uh
so basically you can correct for a
moving frame of reference through
differentiation
and that's kind of the basis of these
integrator chains is something that
might be a moving frame of reference if
you center it by its frame of reference
then it can actually look like something
like a stationary diffusion process and
you get around that by encoding the
system rather in terms of absolute
position something like the velocity or
the momentum of these higher orders of
motion
so yeah i just totally agree with
everything you said basically and it's
like the historical um critique or
comment like well that race car has a
historiosity it's like it is but its
position at the next time point is
determined by its position and
momentum and etc etc etc now
and then that is happening through time
so there is historiosity
we're not ignoring that but we're
setting up the problem with this like
vector of higher derivatives such that
it actually
is being only determined by the next
moment so
absolutely dean
well thanks for stealing all my under
there daniel
i basically was going to ask so
just to make this clear in my head the
metaphor that i drew is you've got
classical mechanics and quantum
mechanics in the room and then busy
mechanics is kind of acting like the
marriage counselor it doesn't really
actually determine
what what is
the you know
the math can't just be precise it just
keeps the two other parties in the room
and has them work out what's
what's a gist and what's a reflection or
am i
am i kind of way
way off in the in the in the reads here
yep so the connection to quantum
mechanics which was made in this one
section of the paper this was actually
something that was suggested by
um
by uh greg pavliotis who is uh lance's
supervisor imperial i'm actually not
convinced that the connection to quantum
mechanics
is as fundamental like so i i basically
i don't think that uh bayesian mechanics
is in between classical and
um
uh classical and quantum mechanics i see
bayesian mechanics
more as
the mechanics of statistical
distributions or basically the moments
of statistical distributions
so in that way if i was to put it in
between two branches of physics i would
probably put it more
at the
three-way in between
classical mechanics
statistical thermodynamics and
stochastic thermodynamics because it's
really uniting
the um
the kinds of coarse-grained expect
expected variables that you deal with
with something like statistical
thermodynamics
with the sorts of motion that you deal
with in things like stochastic
thermodynamics or classical mechanics so
we're talking about the motion of
beliefs or about probability
distributions
and it gets interesting when you have a
markov blanket because then you can
start imbuing the system with these like
quasi-teleological
interpretations of one thing being a
belief about another thing
but the bayesian mechanics per se
actually i think it even
i mean it's it's it's controversial
whether you would call it bayesian
mechanics but there is definitely this
kind of statistical or belief-based
dynamics that you get even in systems
without a mark-off blanket even a
one-dimensional diffusion process where
there's no boundaries or anything you
can describe that system as optimizing
model evidence or minimizing free energy
it's just
it's it's unclear how where where the
bayesian this is because
the bayesian interpretation really comes
in when you're conditioning something on
observations and then you have
uncertainty about another variable that
you can only perceive via the
observations so that's why the markov
blanket i think actually is kind of
fundamental to the bayesian slant on the
mechanics
but even without it you have free energy
minimization and you have
the evolution of beliefs or evolution of
belief distributions it's just they're
not they're not as
they don't have a nice analogy with like
representational mechanics or the things
we're interested in in cognitive science
or biology
yeah that's the part where lance was
talking about gist
and reflection and how a gist
morphs into a reflection and that's
i don't even know how you would put the
math to that but because i don't know i
wouldn't know where to begin but that's
that's where i thought you guys were
headed
am i
am i misled no i think that's right
that's kind of um
it gets that kind of i think the thing
that daniel was saying earlier where
there's
there's the expected internal state
given a particular blanket state but
then there's the idea that any
instantaneous internal state is actually
also encoding an expected external state
whether or not that particular internal
state is the most likely one given the
blanket state so i don't know which of
those would map to gist versus
reflection but that's basically the idea
is that any given realization of the
stochastic process
at any given moment even if it's off is
kind of always parameterizing some just
perception about something on the other
side of the blanket so the markov
blanket the fact that there's a
multivariate system with these kinds of
conditional independencies that really
is fundamental to the interpretation of
saying one side is doing some kind of
just perception of the other side
[Music]
you just don't have one side or the
other without the ability to distinguish
them which i think is a good example
about how the intuition that there are
separable systems
is being built upon in this nexus as you
described with thermodynamics and
statistics and statistical mechanics and
there's other approaches to delineate
subsystems like synergetics trying to
define subsystems geometrically or
trying to define subsystems through
various ways and maybe those will become
integrated as well so steven and then
anyone can write a question or raise
their hand
okay thanks connor for that that
explanation is quite useful as well that
you know when you mentioned that there
can be bayesian inference say on
information coming in
but the blanket
you know gives
it gives a way to to hold that
information i suppose but it i can see
it giving a much more viable route to
integrate many sources
of information which might be also sort
of staggered over time as they come in
and they can be integrated i mean you
can integrate across blankets whereas
if everything's coming in as one mush of
you know all data is coming in through
the same
or or even if it's not directly data but
if if you've only got one
causal
pathway
then you can't necessarily
i can't see a way that you could
disambiguate
and do bayesian inference
between
what we would use blankets for or you
could even say multi-sensory integration
then that becomes a physical channel so
i suppose one question is how would you
think about
different channels of information
as opposed to
different blankets in terms of bayesian
integration
yeah i think the the actual the
multi-channel or multi-sensory
integration story is pretty nicely
accommodated by this and this kind of
brings back to an earlier question that
daniel had about what is the
interpretation of that pi matrix so when
you're thinking about the system
minimizing free energy another way of
thinking about that is it's minimizing
prediction errors
for each of the sensory modalities so if
our blanket states say we have a
three-dimensional external state a
three-dimensional internal state and a
three-dimensional blanket state because
this generalizes to infinite i mean not
infinite but very high integer dimension
our three-dimensional blanket state you
could think of as like eyes ears and
somatosensation or something
and then the the distinct elements of
that pi matrix are basically the weights
that the system that the internal states
are assigning to each of those sensory
channels so if you actually rewrite the
flow of the internal states as a
function of that pi matrix
you can basically see that the internal
states has differential sensitivity to
each of the three
blanket states in fact it's literally
integrating them and the weights it uses
to do that that sum or that average are
provided by the elements of the pi
matrix
so i think the multi-sensory integration
is basically just a higher dimensional
blanket state
what it doesn't get at with what i've
just said is your idea of information
from different channels coming in at
different time lags or different
delays that is what you would have to
accommodate with something like an
integrator chain where
one blanket state is actually a high
order derivative of some other blanket
state or something like that or of an
external state so you can have different
blanket states that from the perspective
of internal states are all coming in at
once but the actual blanket states
themselves are like
longer scale temporal summaries of other
variables one could be the instantaneous
temperature the other could be the time
derivative of temperature the other one
could be the average temperature over an
hour or something like that
also sometimes i think about it like
from a data science example like imagine
if we had three variables that are
getting passed to us like height weight
and favorite color
um maybe that reflects this covariance
matrix like height and weight up there
on the first two
have highest correlation with themself
and then they have less correlation with
each other and then
the off diagonal is not having any
covariance we don't get information
about the favorite color based upon the
other variables say so
multi-sensory
can just be different state variables
that are getting passed through that
vector it doesn't have to be that all
the blanket states are of the same type
the blanket states are just the set of
insulating states
and they don't all have to be
retinal cells now if you were making
this type of a model of the retina it
would be that way but then if you wanted
to make a model of a person who had
sound input light input
etc
you could have the blanket states
reflecting multiple different types then
you get this challenge of
how is the brain integrating different
lags and different precisions etc across
different modalities so that's not the
end of the story but
it it um
is phrased generally enough in the state
space representation
such that we can be discussing in the
same matrix multiple kinds of inputs
yeah exactly
yeah actually conor if you had any
thoughts on this example like how should
we read the you know pi equals what and
then q equals what
right yeah so this is a point where i i
kind of wanted to bring this up earlier
because
i think i i don't know
it would be good i good to talk to lance
about this um i think he's coming to the
next one so maybe he can follow up
but
basically this is actually an example of
a system where
causality does not imply
does basically not exactly correlate
with the markov blanket so in that pi
matrix that's not actually the
covariance right that's the inverse of
the covariance
so that's a really important point
the inverse of the stationary covariance
is not going to have necessarily zeros
in all the same places that the
covariance does
so you could have two variables that
actually have positive or negative
correlation with each other as measured
by the square root of the covariance
that are actually conditionally
independent
so for instance in this example um the
internal which is the first row or the
first column
and the external which is the third row
or the third column they're
conditionally independent of each other
which means there's a zero in the
corresponding entry one three or three
one
so that doesn't mean that the variables
are uncorrelated it means that if i
condition on blanket states the middle
row slash middle column
then there's no more information i can
get
from external states about internal
states or from internal states about
external states it's basically saying
that the internal states get all the
information they possibly can from the
blanket states and the external states
don't add anything else that's actually
a different statement than saying that
there's no stationary
steady-state correlation between
internal and external
and it goes further than that then if
you actually looked at the drift matrix
which is the second equation here
you can see
from the presence of uh elements in the
1 3 and three one elements of that
second equation that big thing that's
like one one point five two
there's actually a direct influence of
internal states on external states in
the sense that the motion
of external states is directly
influenced by internal states so if you
were to integrate that stochastic
differential equation there would be a
causal
if you want to call it that a causal
connection going from internal to
external
but nevertheless because of the way that
the stationary covariance is designed
when you take its inverse
internal is still conditionally
independent of external
so this is a really interesting and kind
of counter-intuitive result that is
talked about a little bit in miguel's
paper it's also talked about a little
bit in an upcoming paper
that is um in review right now
uh that that basically rigorously
defines the conditions under which a
causal connection actually results in
conditional independence between two
variables
so that's basically what the example
here is showing is that you could have
internal directly influence the motion
of external or vice versa but in the
stationary sense they're still
conditionally independent and therefore
the markov blanket is still needed to
mediate information between them
awesome and it was
we'll look forward to these papers um
but that's a really great way of laying
out how we build upon this idea of just
bayesian variables and the graph that
describes them
to dynamical systems and their
covariances through time
and then frame that in terms of flow
which can then be decomposed into this
time reversible and a time irreversible
component ties us into this entire flow
uh
areas of
thermal flow but also information flow
and so also just conor while we have you
let's take this next step which is
let's partition
the blanket states into two kinds of
states
sensory on the incoming and action or
active states on the outgoing so what is
going on with this blanket partitioning
and
how does it relate to active inference
how does active inference relate to this
bayesian graphical approach more
generally
yeah so um here we're basically making
the move of taking the blanket states
and they could be again
of general dimension and then
partitioning them themselves into two
subsets of states
uh active states and sensory states
so if we
if if you basically look at the dynamics
of the system
and you look at the expected variables
you can say that you know the expected
internal state given blanket states is
doing inference about
external states at the same time you can
say that the expected active state
given sensory states is in some sense
minimizing prediction error
so basically minimizing the the
deviation between the expected internal
and the expected external state so
that's where you get along the lines of
uh of basically an active inference
interpretation and i think it's
figure six if i'm not mistaken where
that
yeah or no that's predictive processing
figure eight is where you can basically
show that the active the uh most likely
active state so again this is an
expected active state is minimizing the
sum of precision weighted prediction
errors so the the move here is then you
relate minimizing when you're minimizing
um prediction errors in the context of
inference it's like i'm doing optimal
bayesian inference when i'm minimizing
precision weighted prediction errors in
the context of control it's like i'm
doing pid control which basically
manuel baltierra has shown this in a
paper from a few years ago that is the
sort of prediction error minimization so
now the
elements of that pi matrix become the
weights that you
that you associate to each variable that
you're trying to control in like a pid
system so pid is this kind of
proportional integral derivative control
mechanism
so we don't do this in the paper but if
you were to associate different blanket
states with different like derivatives
along an integrator chain like
the the um integral the derivative and
then the second derivative of some
process
and then those were your blanket states
then you could say that the active the
most likely active state was basically
trying to control the integral
the
first order and then the derivative of a
given system
trying to control them using a pid
control scheme
and where the weights that the pid
controller is assigned to the integral
the first order value and the derivative
those weights would be exactly given by
the entries of the pi matrix that
correspond to the blanket variables
awesome and actually the integrator
chain idea
really connects some dots between this
variational
higher and higher derivatives of
challenging functions variational
inference on nonlinear functions with
planning as inference
so again it's like going back to that
car with the position and the momentum
etc
um
there's one way of working where you
just want to
fit the function of the car
using its again position and higher
derivatives but then what does it look
like when you need to predict the
position of the car so that you can act
and intervene
and so this just connects between this
uh
graphical structure where you can have
arbitrary number of layers of nodes so
from left to right is going through time
but then
vertically within a column
is in a differentiation an integration
relationship so we connect from looking
at a vector
of
position and higher derivatives
connect that to
the kinds of systems that
have uh blanket states
that's just really cool to see
um
yeah
so with yeah go ahead
yeah sorry was there someone else had a
question or go for it connor but anyone
can raise their hand or any questions in
the chat is awesome
i was just going to say
like it's essentially that it's that um
this so if if we were to cast the
blanket variables as these different
higher this vector of higher order
derivatives of a system
just by that system conversion to its
stationary state it would be implicitly
if we started far away from the steady
state it would be implicitly essentially
controlling each of those variables to
some desired set point so that's often
the terminology using control theory is
that i'm trying to keep the velocity
within some range keep the position
within some range keep the acceleration
within some range so if you interpret
the dynamics of the most likely active
state as doing pid control basically
what it's doing is it's punishing
deviations around those desired set
points with some control cost where the
control cost exactly is given by the pid
weight assigned to the acceleration
velocity position which is you can read
off from the inverse of the stationary
covariance i.e the the pi matrix
to kind of give a fun example of that um
one way of looking at this figure 10 in
the helmholtz supplement
is kind of like there's an ink blot and
so there's some forces that have it
dispersing and some that have it staying
together and then when you look down
from the top that's like the steady
state distribution of the ink plot and
so that's sort of a diffusiony way to
look at it but let's look at this as
like a physical hill so the z-score the
the height is they're not not the
statistical z-scores the height is like
um the concentration at steady state of
ink so whatever the diffusion processes
are it's densest right in the middle and
then it gets less so we can think about
that as being like the bottom of the
bowl
and then it gets higher up so when you
drop the marble in the bowl
it's going to on average go to the
bottom of the bowl
and then if you were to think about that
marble as like a control theoretic agent
with its position which is initially not
at the bottom of the bowl and then all
of the higher order derivatives so
initially if it's stopped on the side of
the bowl it's like you're holding the
higher derivatives to be zero then you
release it and gravity takes effect etc
it would almost look like it was like a
plane landing on the bottom of the bull
because it would like accelerate and
then it would slow down its acceleration
and the higher order derivative it would
act
as if it were doing pid control
to converge all of its and then diminish
all the derivatives so that it would end
up
with zero
velocity and the differential from the
mean of the expectation of zero so
that's like kind of an inanimate system
but that shows how this diffusion
flow
field
and then the free energy interpretation
of kind of like the gibbs free energy
dropping into the bowl finding yourself
on the bottom of a physical bowl
is also related to control theory so
there's like
so many of these
important threads to connect together
any other
uh
general comments otherwise i think just
because
we love active inference
what is happening in figure eight like
what is happening on the right side and
maybe why is it not a monotonic uh
drop in free energy which is what we saw
in the other figures
yes so this is um this is basically the
demonstration of what you just said that
on average the system um and that's a
very key point of what of uh just to add
that on to what you said on average the
marble will look like it's trying to get
to the bottom of the bowl
and minimize those deviations from the
different set points for position
acceleration velocity what have you so
this is basically showing that
so i'll just explain the figure on the
left that the white line is basically
the most ac the most likely active state
which is one of the two blanket states
given
various settings of the sensory state so
the white line is saying for any given
setting of the x-axis what is the most
likely setting of the y-axis
but then we also show overlaid on that
expectation which is just a linear line
a linear function of the sensory state
we also show an actual realization of
the process and that's really the the
key thing to note here there's a
difference between expectations
and which are derived from the steady
state to statistics versus realizations
of the process which are contaminated
with all the
nitty-gritty messy things of the real
world like noise and solenoidal flow and
stuff like that so this also goes to
answer your second question about the
plot on the right is why is the system
not doing monotonic decrease on
uh free energy
and the reason is because there's
solenoidal flow
so if there is no solenoidal flow and
you average this descent across
trajectories
an individual trajectory even without
solenoidal flow might still not do
monotonic free energy descent because of
noise so the stack stochastic noise
you're adding to these diffusion
processes can temporarily drive it up
the gradients of the free energy
but if i average across like a thousand
trajectories it would look like a smooth
descent on free energy because all the
noise realizations would be averaged out
and then there would basically just be a
straight line going from wherever you
started this
ensemble of parallel simulations to the
to the bowl the minimum free energy but
because of solenoidal flow which is this
component of the drift that drives the
system along the iso contours of the
probability density which is not
pointing in the direction of the free
energy minimum
because of that even after you average
across trajectories the free energy will
not monotonically go down but it'll
actually follow some average trajectory
that has some curvature to it
um so that's an actually interesting
interpretation in the active inference
sense because it's so showing that on
the way to the free energy minimum it's
not necessarily going to take
the the path laid out by the most likely
active state given sensory states it
might actually take a more circuitous
route and it will end up on the white
line by the time it's at the minimum but
its journey to that white line on
average and in individual realizations
will not actually be along the white
line um and that's a really interesting
there's a connection there to be drawn
to the study of
basically efficient um
diffusion processes that are used in
things like
markov chain monte carlo so people
basically define design diffusions in
order to accelerate convergence to
a stationary target distribution this is
used a lot in like
stochastic
sampling based approximate bayesian
inference and there's actually a lot of
evidence and there's mathematical proof
behind this too that diffusion processes
with this kind of curvature solenoidal
flow are actually better at reaching the
minimum and they do so faster rather
than one that's just doing a direct
descent
on the log probability
which is equivalent to the free energy
nice thank you one one thing i'll point
out about this figure on the left is
that the x-axis has twice the uh
scale as the y-axis
so you can also this white line is like
the y equals x line like it's right at 0
is that that's the bottom of the bowl
and then
it's it's
it's just stretched out a little bit in
one way but it's kind of like that's
just the y equals x line that would be
if the um
that's just the one to one and then it
starts up here with the s of t a of t
and then it kind of finds its way to the
bottom and that connects to figure 10
with the helmholtz decomposition where
just like conor was saying we can
separate out into this solenoidal which
is going like around the isocontour
and then this
um straight-line component and so the
extreme of one case um assuming that
such a line of sight exists is like
you're at the bottom of the mountain and
then you just like straight line up to
the top
but then the kinds of systems that we're
looking at here
are where we can decompose their actions
into an as if straight line that's
always going up the maximum possible
elevation gain to the mountain top or
the maximum possible descent to the
bottom of the bowl
but also there's this wiggle with a
solenoidal coupling that's guaranteed to
be orthogonal to that first component
and that was an interesting point about
designing the kinds of diffusion
processes that do help us
find
whether you phrase it as the top or the
bottom but find the free energy optimal
place on a landscape that might be very
rugged so a lot of misleading
elevation changes
hey daniel
doesn't that just give another feather
in the cap for
interactionism over instructionalism
can you maybe explain that a little more
and then we'll see congress
yeah i think what conor just pointed out
was really
critical if you're if we're optimizing
we have to be
willing to set up condition where
we're not enforcing
a linear
path
that we're actually allowing for the um
what do you want to call it the
degree of variability and that's what
interactionism supports so
i just i was just listening to that
going yeah there's another
there's another proof now we've got the
mathematical evidence
cool it's like work and play a little
bit with um
the most direct way
to get those instructions might be with
a little bit of interaction along the
way they're just they're um
inseparable in the actual realization of
the process
any thoughts on that connor
yeah i think i think that's i mean i'm
always excited when people kind of can
connect solenoidal flow to specific
domains i'm not sure what instructionism
or or interactionism are but i'm
assuming that it's basically saying that
just a linear classic optimization
taking the path of steepest descent is
actually kind of maybe
counterintuitively not always the best
option i think that's just what
solenoidal flow captures in any
stochastic dynamical system is the fact
that there's some curvature
uh to the actual dynamics of systems
where they're not always trying to go to
the mode of the density but they might
actually get where you're trying to go
by kind of taking an alternative route
on the way there and it's just really
cool that mathematically you can show
that that's actually better than taking
the path of steepest descent
it's like the ball can't just go down to
the bottom in a straight line then put
on the brakes the real path takes a
little bit of a different route so
oh yeah oh i want to slip one more thing
in because i i want to give steven a
boost before he speaks
and that is that i've heard steven a
number of times
mention the word trust
and trust takes time
and i think again that interaction and
that that trust piece this this math
confirms that we don't just have to
intuit that there's actually now some
some support for what takes time and
what will actually optimize
maybe the most
sought after outcome
not always necessarily the best but at
least it gives you a
higher likelihood of achieving an
outcome
because you can you can you can now say
trust
takes time but there's there's a sort of
a almost a mathematical imperative to
give more time over to something to
arrive at the best answer
sorry stephen but i just wanted to
you know sort of boost what you've been
saying a lot and i because i i agree
with it
thanks dean
stephen
yeah it's an interesting yeah i think
the trust piece and what you could call
real life i don't know if we would talk
about real life but
a couple of questions that sort of come
from that is saying is like you know if
you're talking about
um this this solenoidal flow is is that
property or that
um does that become
a more
optimal
um
way of achieving
radiant descent when there's more noise
or the more
rugged the landscape i suppose that's my
first question and the other question is
i just wanted your thoughts you
mentioned here like active states so
this idea of like
it's almost like sensory data coming in
on active
states and we often talk about active
states and action states i
what's the states of action
that starts the organism does but i
suppose
internally
you've just got the active states which
are kind of like almost mathematical
codependencies so i'd be interested in
like i say the amount of noise or
ruggedness or approximation that has to
happen and how much the solenoidal if it
if it really makes a difference or
whether the math just is the same if
it's smooth and and and
just your thoughts on how states are
talked about in terms of active or
action
oh if that's something you think about
yeah
um yeah so for your first point so when
you say the ruggedness of the landscape
you mean like it's not just a quadratic
single bump but there might be multiple
bumps
yeah i'm actually not sure i i don't i
don't have any intuitions about why what
solenoidal flow would do in that case i
think like daniel was kind of saying it
might actually be better at finding the
global optimum
the research i'm aware of is just saying
that for even
unimodal distributions like this
sometimes the solenoid flow actually
gets you to
the
unique optimum faster
even though you would think that direct
descent should be fastest in the
presence of noise in the dynamics so not
a rugged landscape but just the dynamics
are perturbed by noise the solar nodal
flow will actually get you to the
optimum faster but in the case of the
actual probability distribution of the
steady state is multimodal and rugged
itself that's a very interesting
question i don't know
i just don't know the research what it
says and i personally don't have any
intuition about whether solano flow
would accelerate convergence to the
global optimum
um or not but i i i would be surprised
if no one's researched that because it's
a very interesting question
and then regarding the active states
versus action
yeah i mean
i guess that i haven't thought that much
about what like what
semantically jumps out to me or what i
associate when i hear active state
versus action but i guess i think of
fluctuations in the active states as
actions so as the active state evolves
that's what i would call an action or an
or a particular realization of an active
state as an action and then the active
state itself we just refer to as the
random variable that's a stochastic
process that evolves over time and we
refer to that as the active state
um so we have the both the
two-dimensional in this case
two-dimensional blanket states one is a
random variable that we call the sensory
state another one is a random variable
we call an active state so that whole
stochastic process
is the active state and maybe individual
realizations of it would be an action
thanks connor
stephen and then anyone else and then
also in this last few minutes if anyone
in the live chat has a question they can
write it so stephen
thanks that that's helpful i think like
you mentioned that i was thinking maybe
particularly about noise so yeah that
makes sense if there's more noise when
there's more
rugged landscape yeah that's an
interesting question
that maybe someone's worked on i was
wondering what you're basically saying
with active states is
there are more flux there's a there's a
greater flux a bit like sensory state
like the information coming in as is
more fluctuating and i.e like well you
could say lights going at billions of
hertz you know or whatever
and then it's the the regularities are
slowing down as it comes in the active
states would be a greater flux
compared to going through the blanket
and the transferring it
to whatever
the perturbations
that are relevant to our model are on
the outside so that's kind of
interesting
one comment on that is um
the actual error dynamics or just
baseline dynamics of each of these kinds
of states it's going to depend on the
system but when we're thinking about
biological systems yes the action states
can be conditioned on what the system is
like if there's one degree of freedom on
the elbow joint then it's a
dimensionally reduced
in comparison to the incoming
sensory data for example so
active states end up kind of saving the
day in a lot of ways which is why it is
such a clutch advance in the field to
partition the otherwise just co-mingling
blanket states into this kind of
incoming and outgoing because then we
can assign those incoming states and the
statistically causal chains coming
inbound we can associate that with
inference and with
everything related to predictive
processing and then on the outbound from
the internal states going back out to
the active states we can associate that
with cybernetics control theory and also
planning as inference so the
partitioning is is a is an immensely
important maneuver steven and then
anyone else
yeah and also the active states become a
proprioceptive
form of i mean really appropriate
perceptive form of sensory input in a
funny sort of way like
in the sense that how much they change
so for instance you push your i'm kind
of curious where there's this blending
you know you put your hand on a on a hot
on a wall and you push you're sensing
the wall
but you're also sensing your active
states aren't changing as much
that makes sense because the wall is
stopping them
there's an interest in
but that that all could be happening at
this kind of
fluctuating speed
however like you just mentioned
the system structure will
the fact that you've got an elbow and
the fact that it allows certain things
to happen is going to make all that come
into
context of the system you know so that's
quite cool
yep um sorry if there's any noise there
but yes when the um person is pushing on
the wall they might be getting a
different than expected or less than
expected
amount of change in their sensory input
wow it's really loud i'm just going to
view it for a second
incredible times so
um both conor and lance have uh departed
for today and i believe that we'll be
talking with at least lance next week in
the 26.2
so in this last 10 minutes or so
let's look back over the paper and any
of the other figures and let's think
about what we want to ask or what we'd
like to explore
in that dot too
so
who has any thoughts of this
i got i have a thought
i didn't raise my hand sorry um
at some point the the 60 year old me
would like
some of this be to be brought down to
six-year-old me in terms of the
sophistication of the math and sort of
maybe
maybe walk through some more of those um
the ability to be able to explain to
somebody that there isn't that there is
a an underpinning of math that explains
what this medium is about and why
things pass through it and and
and necessarily allow these two
differentiated states to work
i know that i know that they have to be
able to explain it in
in on the level because it's it's
complexity so they have to be able to
use a certain sophistication of math but
if there's some way for them
to be able to bring that down to the my
pedestrian level my six-year-old level
that would be fantastic because then
i think it would be a lot easier for
people to climb on board with the idea
that
some of this some of this
bayesian mechanics stuff
um doesn't have to remain remain elusive
or out there but it's actually
something useful that we can incorporate
into a lot of the practices that we
would like people to adopt
thanks
dean agreed good thing to think about
and also dave wrote in the chat we seem
to be convinced that some kinds of
partitioning simplify analysis great
point so
um internal external blanket is not the
only partitioning of how you can
partition nodes in a bayesian network
and sense an action isn't the only
partitioning that is possible for
blanket states so different ways of
partitioning the problem
are going to
variously set it up in a way that's
going to be confusing
or impossible to solve or
challenging to solve or potentially easy
to solve and sort of the exemplar of the
easy problem to solve
computationally not the only example but
just one example is like again the ball
rolling to the bottom of a hill smooth
ball
perfect gravity
convex optimization it's very easy if
you know that the shape of the bowl is a
quadratic function then all you have to
do is just yep go downhill wherever you
are really simple heuristic algorithm
for getting to the bottom of that
quadratic bowl
and then we look out on the ruggedness
and on the changingness of the fitness
landscapes or of the free energy
landscapes for real systems
and the entire question is again how can
we partition nodes or take the
derivative of sets of nodes or of
different random variables so that we
can make that rugged landscape and
transform it or at least act on a smooth
landscape
so that's sort of the broad theme is can
we just
cut things up
and reframe them
so that our challenge is more like the
marble going down the bowl
rather than bushwhacking you know and
we're just totally lost and we don't
even have a sense of whether we're going
up or down and all of our motion is for
naught so stephen and then anyone else
yeah i suppose in a way our cognition is
trying to help us make things look more
and more like things are rolling down a
bowl
and it's a smoother more
clear picture of the world you know as
we get older so it'd be interesting
maybe to ask a couple more questions
about how noise um
i know
how noise i mean often they use the
infomax
or softmax the infomax function i think
in a lot of active inference modeling
you know to add
some noise
or to add some distributions so i'd be
interested in how
where does the covariance
break down where does it
start to become more coherent smoother
and just their thoughts on that seems to
be quite
that seems to be relevant
beyond
this particular paper thanks dean
yeah one last thing
so
to me
what i see is is
the math now
on paper talking about possibility not
talking about
certainty i still think that what this
does is it opens up
the possibility this this map opens up
the possibility as opposed to arriving
at a certain outcome i think all it does
is open up that space that's what that
markov blanket to me essentially does is
it keeps the door open
i know it's described as a as a blanket
but i honestly think it what it does is
it it creates an openness for more math
to be able to flow in and so
just i know they're not philosophers but
i'd like to hear some of their
philosophy around
what that what that does because i think
if people want to say oh well your math
doesn't answer all the all the all the
questions
fine but it does open up a lot of things
that previously we couldn't even say
we're open to your point
so i'd like to find out what their
philosophical
positions are now that they've been able
to
sort of bring this math to a place where
it does
prove out
cool dean thank you and yes what you
said there about like
uh from certainty into uncertainty and
of course always leaving that room for
the interaction
it puts everything
on the the uncertainty
and the precision are there two sides of
the same coin the precision is the
inverse covariance so if two things are
perfectly covariate there's like a one
or a high number in that matrix
then your precision is high
um uh so
or
just
it's in the math but yes if they're
variable with respect to each other then
knowing one doesn't tell you about the
other if they're not variable with
respect to each other then knowing one
gives you high precision on the other
and it puts all kinds of state
inferences
on this continuum of precision so
pretty awesome conversation really
helpful that we were able to speak with
the authors and yeah next week in 26.2
we'll look forward to maybe seeing some
more of you on the stream
having any people submit questions if
they want to ask something or
just have us
digest it or
modify a question at all
but as you said very
important contributions and scales
beyond the paper so thanks again
everybody and we'll see you next week
thanks daniel bye thanks bye